wie sicher sind unsere daten wirklich
ein hacker des chaos computer clubs
zeigt wie man anhand eines normalen
fotos auf dem die hände zu sehen sind
den fingerabdruck rekonstruieren kann
was können wir gegen die schwindende
sicherheit im alltag und im netz
unternehmen jetzt bei klick zum science
fiction
das internet ist schon seit langem kein
sicherer ort mehr beinahe täglich
erreichen uns nachrichten von
hacker-angriffen auf die mailserver
banken große unternehmen und sogar ganze
staaten das nicht einmal unsere
hochrangigen politiker davor geschützt
den zeigt ein aktueller vorfall eine
mitarbeiterin eine enge mitarbeiterin
von angela merkel brachte versehentlich
ein mit einem spionage programm
infizierten usb-stick mit dem das
kanzleramt sie hatte sich den virus zu
hause auf ihren privaten laptop
eingefangen die virus namens legend
kopierte sich von diesem laptop auf den
usb-stick und von dort aus auf einen
arbeits- laptop der bundesregierung
der trojaner wurde zwar sofort erkannt
als die mitarbeiterin den usb stick in
den gesicherten computer steckte er
hätte aber sehr sensible daten der
kanzlerin preis fliegen können experten
vermuten hinter der software dragon
entweder eine supermacht wie die usa
oder china ein so komplexes aufwändiges
und gut getan das programm können nur
von sehr mächtigen staaten in auftrag
gegeben werden
die spionage software ist auf
programmiert screenshots zu machen
gelöschte dateien einzusammeln und
passwörter zu klauben besonders
passwörter stellen heutzutage ein großes
sicherheitsrisiko dar sind sie erst
einmal geknackt bieten sie dem hacker
vollen zugriff auf den account und die
darauf gespeicherten daten
doch gibt es überhaupt noch eine
alternative zum passwort wer seine daten
ohne passwort absichern will dem fall
schnell sogenannte biometrische scans 1
sie sollen den computer mit etwas
absichern an dass niemand anderes
herankommt mit den maßen des eigenen
körpers fingerabdrücke zum beispiel die
netzhaut der augen oder die gesamte
gesichtspartie das alles soll erhöhte
sicherheit bieten und das lästige merken
und eingeben von passwörtern abschaffen
doch dass diese biometrischen daten
sogar noch einfacher zu knacken sind als
passwörter beweist nun der chaos
computer club
er demonstrierte mit hilfe des hackers
whistler wie einfach es ist einen
fingerabdruck einer anderen person
erhalten anhand eines normalen
hochauflösenden pressefotos von
verteidigungsministerin ursula von der
leyen und mit einem 400 euro teuren
programm
er stellte er große teile ihres
fingerabdrucks den rest könnte man mit
fotos von anderen blickwinkeln
vervollständigen dazu benötigte er
keinen gegenstand wie zum beispiel ein
wasserglas auf dem sich der
fingerabdruck befindet 2012 wurde ja
wolfgang schäubles fingerabdruck auf
diese weise dupliziert und
veröffentlicht auch netzhaut scans sind
keineswegs sicher die meisten programme
lassen sich mit üblichen ausgedruckten
fotos überlisten
einfacher kann man das den hackern kaum
machen laut experten ist und bleibt die
sicherste methode um seine daten zu
schützen immer noch das gute alte
passwort eben doch denn das bleibt im
gegensatz zu den biometrischen daten im
kopf und wird nicht überall wo man hin
fasst oder hinguckt verteilt computer
brauchen je nach länge des passwortes
zwischen einer mikrosekunde und 35
trilliarden jahren um ein passwort zu
knacken das ist unglaublich lange
existieren und ich weiß nicht es kommt
also durchaus auf die länge an
doch selbst extrem lange passwörter für
die ein normaler computer tausende jahre
benötigen würde könnten von einem
quantencomputer in sekundenschnelle
geknackt werden ein quantencomputer
arbeitet mit vier statt wie herkömmliche
computer mit zwei verschiedenen
zuständen und kann deshalb wesentlich
kompliziertere aufgaben in extrem kurzer
zeit lösen
wer jetzt denkt dass karten computer
erst in ferner zukunft funktionieren
werden der täuscht sich
bereits 2012 wurde in china ein quanten
netzwerk installiert und praktisch
eingesetzt
beim damaligen 18 kongress der
kommunistischen partei dann keine
informationen nach draußen
wenn ihr mehr über diesen fortschritt
der technik erfahren wollt dann klickt
hier um zum video zu lang und hier unten
geht es wie immer zu rap und zum blog
und jetzt bin ich natürlich auf eure
meinung zum thema gespannt wie sieht ihr
die zukunft unserer daten im internet
sind sie überhaupt abzusichern
diskutiertes wie immer mit mir in den
kommentaren und ansonsten bis zum
nächsten mal
bis dann bleibt dran